hello everyone and welcome to inclusive
design and testing making your app
accessible my name is Maya Benari I'm a
product manager on Android accessibility
with me today is Casey Burkhardt who is
an engineer on Google accessibility team
and we'll also have Mahal who runs
applicable applicable Google tel-aviv
program Meehan will be joining us by
video we are very excited we're very
excited to have you all in the session
today and thank you all for coming our
agenda will start with a brief overview
about accessibility then we'll tell you
more about the applicable Google
tel-aviv program will dive into
inclusive design best practices and
we'll have a section about testing so
first what is the what is accessibility
accessibility is about creating products
that are usable by everyone this
includes also users with disabilities
such as vision impairment or motor
impairments but I'd like to rephrase
this definition slightly differently and
I would say that accessibility is about
challenging the assumptions we make
about our users for example can the
users see the device can he or she
distinguishes between color can the user
touch the device and can the user hear
the sound that the device is producing
and speak back to the device now this is
not a small number that we are talking
about 20% of the US population will have
some sort of a disability during their
lifetime but this is not all challenging
the assumption we make will benefit all
users and some of the technologies that
we're developing the past such as speech
recognition and work prediction started
as technologies for users with
accessibility needs
but this is not all we are all users
with accessibility needs some time this
is called situational disability for
example when we drive our car we cannot
look at our device when we are in a
noisy environment we cannot listen to
the sound that the device is producing
and we cannot speak back to the device
and when we carry heavy bags from the
supermarket we can use we cannot use our
hands to interact with the device so we
want to create an inclusive experience
for all our users regardless of what
restriction they might have now in the
next section we are going to tell you
more about applicable Google tel-aviv
program so what is applicable applicable
is the program that helps startup to
make their app more accessible and
applicable does so by inviting developer
and startups to their campus to witness
how blind and modern impaired user are
using their apps so this is the video
that me Hal Walker from Google Tel Aviv
just sent us let's move to the video my
name is Ilana vanish and I am 38 years
old I born blind
I had many surgeries and they have
succeeded to improve my sight in one eye
independency means access many of the
technologies that available today are
not accessible and that's why I came to
lickable anyways we have on the program
manager of chapter salvia which is a
Google space that is dedicated to
entrepreneurs and startups meaning
helping the local ecosystem to create
amazing start
oops I started thinking how is it
possible that this huge market is not
being addressed because if they knew
that with some easy steps they can
actually make their app accessible to
the shoes market I was sure that they
bound to do something about this so this
is how the idea of this problem of
applicable started my name is Arielle
Kayden I'm mobile product manager fiber
fiber is a marketplace for creative
professionals we're helping people
productize and make money from their
talent five is trying to change how
people work and allowing people with
disabilities to work with fiber is
something big so we started with
visually impaired and blind people each
table had a start-up mentors from the
design world from the product world and
developers set together with person with
visual impairment and a person who was
blind to see how he's actually using his
own app my name is jonathan and her
developer and evangelist in get get is a
leading platform for on-demand services
like get taxi or and get pizza or even
get the doctor and remember at the
beginning it was a woman saying are you
from get i'm not talking with you like
you're making my life awful when you
make this difference for them personally
feel proud it was like you really helped
someone one of the really small changes
that we did that has huge impact was
that we have when you open the app we
have marketing pop up right straight on
the screen and it don't have any label
so for the for the blind people was like
home we're sort of showing a regular map
with the address and and order taxi
button and wasn't what's the word that
they're actually there marketing pop up
and they can't click on anything or
using the talkback
and by just verifying that if you are
the dog book is turn off not to showing
this pop-up is like huge difference
because now these people were able to
order text instead of constantly
clicking on the marketing poppin
understanding why can't order a taxi but
actually that the impact was that she
went out of the building and she said oh
now able to order the taxi
actually did some really small change we
have a page of categories within fiber
it was built like poor category next to
a category and a very long page and when
we did one of the session they just tell
me just build them one in one in a row
and not one next to each other so we
change it we put it in they have on page
and just change dramatically how people
navigate they're thinking about a simple
experience it just made me a better
product manager but it's a really small
effort just to change really the bytes
of code to add additional stuff and you
can make really huge difference for them
for their daily they tagging your
components on a specific page giving
and image the right I'll it's really
something that when you change I think
it's very simple enable the accessible
view on your phone try to use the phone
as someone who just for example can see
this will affect everything you do
dramatically unlabeled button thirteen
unlabeled but and seventy-four unlabeled
button but an eighteen unlabeled button
thirty-five unlabeled button disaster we
did a disaster so after about half a
year that leads out of the visual
impairment and blindness we went to the
second stage of the program and
addressed people with motor disabilities
so again we open testing labs we bought
the Mentos we brought people with
disabilities we brought startups and we
realized that this is definitely
something that is so needed thank you
for joining in start running try to send
message during the the running you will
have a lot of respect and you need to
duration we type using 39 years old and
working and guests as they senior QA
engineers and I have several for the
effect of that you can see my speeches I
have a difficult speech and by the white
hand is
McConkey and also both the legs are not
function and I have only one hand and
even in I think I have in three fingers
I have a spastic it's very difficult to
test to reach all the corners with one
finger my wildest dream I will have the
ability to put every each button in the
place that I want another thing the
diviners guys weeks we got but but it
will make that more accessible for me
and for the others to meet with them to
tell them our needs it was very very
important meetings my message to all
developers will be hey guys you are
there you actually the one that can have
the power to change for a lot of people
who entirely like I think about this
amazing applicable session every stream
page or button the time heading to that
we got more so now the ball accessible
apps are changing our lives every day
and will continue to change everybody's
life
every day
so I'd like to take to thank Mahalo from
campus Google Tel Aviv applicable
program for sending us this wonderful
video from the video we saw that
sometime small changes may have big
impact on people lives for example as
Jonathan from gasps Jonathan is here by
the way
just adding labeling to the app that was
previously not accessible made a huge
difference and finally and then like
suddenly a user who couldn't use their
app could now order a cab so in the next
section we're going to get into
specifics a suggestion on how to create
a more inclusive experience for all
users so first what is inclusive
designer every product decision that we
make in our app may include or exclude
certain type of users so what we want is
to take into this consideration those
people with a different need entities
and to design our app which is reachable
and accessible to the different users
that's all sounds good but how do we do
that so the first thing that you need to
do is to be familiar and try the
different accessibility services this is
what applicable program is doing is you
want to understand the experience of
different users with different needs so
first what is an accessibility service
an accessibility service is a
long-running privilege service that can
do one of two things one it changes the
way the user interact with the design we
interact with
vice or second it changes the way that
the content is represented to the users
now today we have four different
accessibility services available on the
platform
the first one is talkback talkback is
targeted for blind and visually impaired
user and it's basically a screen reader
that the user can interact with user
using gesture and the content is
represented through text-to-speech now
let's take a look at that one let's
switch to the demo so now I'm inside of
Android settings in accessibility and I
can go in to talk back and turn talkback
on talkback on I'll go to button spring
home screen one of one home screen one
of one so we've talked back the user has
two ways to interact with the device the
first one is called linear navigation so
basically for whatever icon or element
that currently has focused the user can
use swipe gesture to move between
elements phone for example messenger
apps know when the user wants to
activate a specific element he can
basically double tap anywhere on the
screen and the element that currently
has focus will open up apps clock so
this is linear navigation the second way
for a user to interrupt is called
explore by touch in this case the user
will put one finger down and then he can
navigate across the screen and every
element that gains focus talkback will
read out loud
let's take a look better bad calculator
click Chrome drive gmail clock now when
the user would like to open that element
again
he can tap anywhere on the screen and
the element that has focus will open up
Clark this is talkback the second
service that we have is called
brailleback browser items wanted to of
to thank you talk back the second the
second service that we have on the
platform today is called Braille back
now with Braille back the user is
interacting with a refreshable Braille
display such as this one in this case
the user have this keyboard or the
joystick and you can interact similarly
to how the user interacts with talkback
just in this case the content is going
to be represented in Braille on those
Braille cells with the dog raising and
lowering so this is Braille back the
third service we have on the platform is
called switch access switch access is
targeted for motor impaired users who
have trouble interacting with a
touchscreen in this case the user can
connect something which is called an
adaptive switch like this one in this
switch this switch has two buttons it
can have more or less button in this one
in this one the user will set one of the
button is next and one of the button is
select then the interaction with switch
access will be similar to the linear
navigation of totebag just in this case
the user will interact using the buttons
rather than gestures let's go to the
slides please now the last service is
called voice access this is a service we
recently launched and the user can
perform low-level interaction using
using his voice if you would like to
learn more about this one
we have the access and empathy sandbox
just outside of this room now note those
are representative examples of the
capabilities of accessibility api's
every developer can develop services
similar this one but you can use those
one to actually test are how your app
interacts with accessibility services
now if you would like to focus on only
two services please test with switch
access and talkback why is that
cuz with switch access what you can test
is how accessibility services interact
with your UI which is basically testing
your input and with talkback what you
are going to test is how content is
represented to the user for example
whether you have labeling so you will
test the output so we switch access and
topic you are going to test both your
input and output okay so until now we
are familiar with the different
accessibility services now what you want
to make sure is that your application
wok works well with those and how do you
do that you following Android
accessibility best practices in the next
part of the presentation we brought to
you couple of highlights that we gather
from our testing data so these are our
top four common suggestion based on
testing data of how to improve app
accessibility we have content labeling
touch target size contracts and view
attributes now note this is not a
comprehensive list but these are small
changes that you can do in your app that
may have a significant input exit a
significant impact
the first one is content labeling why do
we need that this is for visual impaired
or blind user who rely on screen reader
to understand what's going on
specifically screen readers need content
description to understand UI elements
without visible text this is what we saw
in the applicable video but an 86 on
label but a 99 on label so what you want
is to use contact description in your
XML layout to describe the elements for
editable UI element our recommendation
is slightly different in this case use a
droid hint or a droid label for for
anything which is editable now the next
big question is how do I write my
content labeling and our most important
frame recommendation is make sure your
labeling make sense so these are a
couple of do or don't read regarding to
labeling for example if you have an
account switcher what how you should
describe the content switch to a gmail
some kind of a demo account at gmail.com
what you don't want to do is to add a
Content labeling such as accounts which
are switch to account my demo at
gmail.com so please be succinct with
your comp with your content labeling
while describing enough context the next
one is if you have a close button what
you want to provide is labeling such as
close you don't want to provide the
labeling for a close button because in
that case the screen
reader my treaty as a close button
button so please don't include the type
or the state of the UI element now the
last one my last example if you have a
pencil on top of an image button use
content labeling such as edit and not
pencil so please describe the action and
not the image now our second
recommendation is about increasing touch
target size this will allow users with
mobility impairments to interact with
actionable UI elements so what we'd like
you to do is to make your touch target
size big enough what is big enough we
recommend using touchable items larger
than 48 by 48 DP now it doesn't mean
that the whole image needs to be 48 by
48 as you can see here with the
magnification glass in that one the
image is only 24 by 24 but we want that
the touch area which responds to user
input will be bigger than 48 by 48 now
you can extend the touchable bounds
beyond the view size using touch
delegate so for the next example and to
talk about contrast I'd like to invite
casey onto the stage
thanks Maya my name is Casey Burkhardt
I'm a software engineer on Google's
accessibility engineering team our third
best practice today is about contrast
ultimately this comes down to how well
how visually distinguished to your
elements in your UI are this comes down
to the colors we choose to represent
content in our UI the way we measure
contrast is by looking at the luminance
the brightness of the colors used in the
foreground and background of an
individual UI element having a high
level of contrast in our apps is
important for users with visual
impairments but also for people with
light sensitivity like myself and we
want to ensure that we meet a minimum
level of contrast between the colors we
choose for the foreground and the
background of our content
now there are a bunch of tools online
that will allow you to to plug in your
color values and obtain what we call a
contrast ratio this is simply a ratio of
the luminance of the foreground to
background there are a number of tools
online that can be really helpful to go
and identify these and we'll actually
see one in just a bit so specifically
what do we recommend for any use of
images or iconography in your
application we recommend a contrast
ratio of four point five to one meaning
either the foreground or the background
is going to be four and a half times
brighter than the other for text content
our recommendation varies based on the
size of text if your text is large
that's 18 scale pixels or larger we
recommend a ratio of three to one for
text any smaller than that we recommend
the four point five to one ratio and on
this slide we can actually see a few
examples of color primary color
combinations and how they stack up in
terms of contrast ratios so as we can
see white and yellow on black and white
and yellow on blue both meet the
four-point-five ratio but note that
white or yellow on
bread should only be used in combination
with large text we also see a few
examples of color combinations that
don't work well such as blue on black
red blue or white on yellow these
shouldn't be used in in combination with
one another our fourth and final best
practice for accessibility inclusive
design is all around how your
application represents its views within
the view hierarchy
Android's accessibility services will
use view attributes to determine how to
represent and navigate content within
your app here we have an example of a
very simple demo application with two
buttons we're going to use switch access
as an example to see how the application
is interacted with with the
accessibility service so in this case
the layout is very simple for button 1
it's simply a standard Android button
within a linear layout it is clickable
by default so let's see how switch
access interacts with this widget when
we try to click it let's roll the clip
so switch access focus is going to move
to the first button we'll hit select and
we see a little snack bar at the bottom
indicating that the button has been
clicked this is the exact behavior we're
looking for it's simple and works as
expected
now we'll complicate the example a
little bit for button 2 in this case
we'll add an additional linear layout
and we'll mark it as Android clickable
equals true now this represents that we
have 2 clickable things in our hierarchy
the button and its parent linear layout
this can actually create some confusion
and difficulty when using this
application with switch access let's try
it out in all the clip so we're going to
move focus to button 2 we're going to
hit select
we're actually presented with a menu
where the user has to choose do they
want to select the higher level
clickable item or the lower level
clickable item and this is confusing
because the user doesn't need to know
the details about our applications view
hierarchy so we forced the user to
memorize that they need to click 1 or 2
within a
to kill our application this is rather
confusing but we can luckily fix this
pretty easily so the right fix here is
since this linear layout is not actually
clickable will remove the clickable
attribute alternatively since this
layout really isn't used for anything
else we can just remove the layout
entirely view attributes can also affect
how screen readers navigate content and
present content users within your
application
here we have an example of a receipt we
have information in this UI that is
associated we have a subtotal tax and a
grand total that has a key value
relationship with other views on the
screen since these values are associated
what we'd really want is this
information to be spoken as one logical
unit by the screen reader as you can see
in this example we just have a single
relative layout with two standard text
views nothing is defined as focusable so
each of these text views is going to be
focused and spoken independently by a
screen reader and this has the potential
to create a confusing experience because
the screen reader user may not be able
to associate this information linearly
so what do we do instead luckily the fix
here is pretty simple
anytime we have a layout that groups
associated information we simply set
Android focusable equals to true and we
will see now that the screen reader
focuses that content and speaks it as
one logical unit which is the behavior
we want here so we've seen a number of
examples of accessibility best practices
what to do and what not to do but
there's a lot more than just these four
you may find that throughout your
development process you run into unique
accessibility challenges so we encourage
you all to go and review the material
design best practices for accessibility
a link will be in the spaces for this
talk so now that we know about androids
accessibility services how to use them
and we know about androids accessibility
best practices let's talk about applying
them and integrating this testing for
best practices into our development
process and with that let's talk about
testing there are the our recommended
approach to testing for accessibility is
manual testing as you've seen in the
applicable video people engineers
startups are learning exactly how users
with accessibility needs are using their
apps through one-on-one interaction this
is a great example of how to do manual
testing it is the most reliable way to
find the user experience pain points
within our apps so we recommend that you
go and learn about each of androids
accessibility services and try them out
in your app now there are some
challenges with this it takes a lot of
time to actually go through an app with
each of these services and scaling this
across multiple applications can be a
rather large endeavor understanding the
user experience takes a lot of time and
at least understanding what is expected
of each of these accessibility services
also finding just eyeballing an
application looking at it it's sometimes
difficult to assess some aspects of
accessibility it's difficult to
sometimes say oh yes the contrast is too
low here or this touch target is
slightly below the guideline so what we
wanted to do was build a set of tools
that could make these tasks easier for
development teams so we've created the
Android accessibility testing framework
and this is a Java Android library that
is intended to look at Android UI
constructs and make assessments for
accessibility
we'll make recommendations for things
you can improve in your applications uy2
to make things a little more accessible
to people who need it so this framework
is integrated with a number of other
testing tools that we're going to
discuss now the first is espresso it's a
UI testing framework for Android and
we've integrated with espresso and
another framework robolectric for unit
testing in a way that allows you to use
your existing
tests to leverage coverage for
accessibility so how does this work we
have one class it's called accessibility
checks and it's used between espresso
and robolectric to enable accessibility
testing functionality in your current
tests so in espresso I simply call
accessibility checks that enable within
my test classes setup method and in
robolectric I simply annotate my test
class with accessibility checks now when
I go and run my when I go on and run my
tests we'll get some output and here's
an example of that this is a robolectric
test that I've written for a test
application and this test itself asserts
nothing about accessibility
it simply asserts that clicking a button
performs some action because I've
annotated this test class with
accessibility checks we get
accessibility evaluation behavior for
free anytime robolectric interacts with
one of our views so as our test clicks
on this view we actually run our
accessibility tests and we found that
this view is missing a spoken
description for a screen reader so this
would be a good cue for you to go look
at your content labeling make sure
you've provided content descriptions or
appropriate labels so in this case we
actually prevented an accessibility bug
from getting checked into our apps
codebase by relying on accessibility
tests in other tests our other test
frameworks
now that's great for engineers Oh what
about other members of product
development teams have development teams
well we wanted to build a tool that
leverage the power of androids
accessibility test framework for other
project contributors too so Google's
recently shipped accessibility scanner
at the end of March it's a tool for all
members of product development product
development teams technical or
non-technical alike it allows for quick
on device real-time evaluations of
accessibility and will present
suggestions for improving accessibility
within your app very quickly and easily
let's actually take a look at how
accessibility scanner work
in practice that let's switch to the
demo okay so here I have a device with
accessibility scanner installed and
enabled there's a floating action button
that appears on top of every UI and I'll
open up a test application that we
created which intentionally introduced
some accessibility issues to run an
evaluation I'll simply tap on the
scanner button and in just a few seconds
we'll see an overlay showing us which
areas of our you I may need some work
let's take a look at a few suggestions
here so it looks like this item is
missing a description for a screen
reader we should go back and look at the
content description we may have missed
here it looks like we have a small touch
target here we can even get the
specifics about the current size and it
looks like we may have some low contrast
text it looks like we only have a
contrast ratio of 1.9 here so we'll want
to fix that accessibility scanner makes
it easy to look at all the issues within
your applications UI and even take those
issues and share them with my
development team now we can go and get
these bugs fixed we get a simple report
with a screen shot and we can send that
off now that we know we can go and fix
our issues let's see how accessibility
scanner performs on a on a UI where
we've taken its suggestions into account
looks like we're in good shape that's
accessibility scanner a few final words
on automated testing think of these
automated testing tools as a way to get
first pass valuations of your apps for
accessibility we will not be able to
find every accessibility issue that it
happened they have and we won't be able
to fully understand what a user
experiences for various users with
accessibility needs so we do really
advocate manual testing with androids
accessibility services to get that full
picture
finally our testing tools are only as
good as your use of them or the coverage
of your other tests in robolectric and
espresso you're only going to be able to
evaluate controls that you interact with
so you want to make sure that your test
coverage is good if you expect good
coverage from the accessibility
automated tools
similarly accessibility scanner can only
evaluate the things that it sees on the
screen in that present time you may need
to do separate evaluations for portrait
versus landscape currently so just a few
caveats these tools are here to help you
identify things quickly and prevent bugs
from being checked in but always use
manual testing approaches to validate
your user experience and with that I'd
like to hand it back to Maya to wrap up
Thank You Casey further Thank You Casey
for the lively demo lovely demo so you
saw today inclusive design can create a
better experience for everyone
and we recommend following these threes
first first get familiar with the
experience for users with accessibility
needs by trying out accessibility
services specifically please try out
talkback and switch access second follow
accessibility best practices in the next
slide we're going to present couple of
links we'll also share those links on
these talk spaces and finally
development as with accessibility in
mind and we provided today some tools
such as Android testing framework we
draw electorate and espresso and
accessibility scanner to try those out
now find a word the sooner you consider
for accessibility
the sooner you consider accessibility
users their needs the better you can
address those needs and design a better
experience in your app to include all
type of users so these are a few links
this is what's next
waiting for people to take a pictures
okay all good one more one work and I'd
like to thank Casey and thank me hull
for creating this session thank you
everyone